in a city known for its Lakes this
floating plastic sphere no bigger than a
baseball led to a surprising discovery
for researchers about what's in the
water we found uh RSV we found influenza
we found SARS that includes SARS K2 the
virus responsible for the co 19 pandemic
their findings after testing several
Halifax area lakes now published in
scientific reports the results so novel
the study's authors can't answer yet
what it means for anyone wanting to take
a dip in a lake although the who has
said coid 19 doesn't transmit through
water right now I couldn't really say
like this is safe or not safe because we
don't have a lot of benchmarks is this
uh normal or abnormal we we don't really
know there isn't really any literature
like this out there that's exciting
though you know we we can hopefully use
this to try to understand
more for Hayes the these are the key to
that understanding each ball holds a
small bag of activated carbon which
soaks up water and the viruses in it
which is later extracted and measured
she came up with the design 2 years ago
after brainstorming ways to measure coid
19 in Wastewater the sewers can be quite
aggressive sometimes with the flow so I
wanted something that could easily
bounce around and and not be easily
damaged so the the ball served to to do
that well and then it allows um us to
easily deploy our absorb material
without you know fouling the the
membrane we would deploy um Samplers at
various locations weekly um and kind of
bring them back to the lab and then I
would analyze them the researchers hope
this small ball will make a big impact
when it comes to testing fresh water not
just here but around the world this tool
far easier to use than traditional
testing methods which can require
collecting up to 1,500 L of water at a
time and so several are making their way
to other Sun scientists searching for
pathogens in bodies of water South of
the Border and in Africa water is so
important to in so many parts of our
Lives an innovation they hope will
someday mean safer cleaner water for all
Heidi pic Global News Dartmouth Nova
Scotia